so much it's such an honor in such a
pleasure to be part of the opening
ceremony of the 50th World Economic
Forum and yet Klaus for 50 years you
have brought together here in Davos the
brightest people of our times and for 50
years your thinking has always been
ahead of times you have always had a
vision on how to shape a better future
for Europe and the world and you always
wanted to bring together people from
different backgrounds the
multi-stakeholder concept you just
mentioned it which is now so essential
to solve from tomorrow's challenges 50
years ago you conceived the idea of the
World Economic Forum you were one of the
first to question Europe's dependence on
fossil fuels already a few years before
the great oil crisis you were one of the
first to called for more sustainable
economic growth 50 years ago indeed you
described a clash between two ideas of
capitalism these two ideas are widely
known as as you said the shareholder
capitalism and the stakeholder
capitalism the first model only cares
about shareholder profit the second the
one you always believed in is about
social responsibility responsibility
towards workers and their families
responsibility towards our environment
responsibility toward society as a whole
your father dear Klaus was a friend of
Ludwig jihad you told me and you said
that his concept of Ljubljana marked
wirtschaft social market economy shaped
your early thinking and this is also the
political culture I do come from and let
me say with some pride but 50 years on
it is more needed than ever today I
would call it an economy that works for
people and this is what you had already
in mind a half a century ago
indeed in January 1971 when a group of
European business leaders met for the
very first time here in Davos it was
under the patronage of the European
Commission and they have been coming
back here every January since then
setting the agenda for the year ahead
just as Davos has gone from strength to
strength so has its partnership with the
European Commission back in the 1970s
great Europeans like ralf dahrendorf and
Altiris Benelli represented the European
Commission in the Davos debates later in
the 1990s Commissioner Leon Brittan was
here to discuss the moral implications
of globalization and the debate
continues in fact we are now exploring
ways to make our partnership even closer
and more fruitful for our continent
I am convinced as you are Klaus that a
more just the sustainable economic
system is possible for too long
humanity took away resources from the
environment and in exchange produced
waste and pollution I believe as you do
that we can reconcile our economy with
our planet we can reconcile human
development with the protection of our
home but we can only do it together
dear Klaus Davos has always been about
building international cooperation and
coordination because sustainable
progress and sustainable peace are
impossible to reach without common
action among nations
Davos is the place who are leaders who
otherwise wouldn't even speak to each
other engage in debates Davos is the
place where conflicts are averted
business is started disputes are
finished Davos is the place where
government business and civil society
join forces and ladies and gentlemen
traditionally Davos is a call for action
to politicians and CEOs but to make
truly global impact we need a broad
engagement by everyone and more and more
Davos is becoming a place where civil
society can make its voice heard the
voice of NGOs the voice of scientists
and the academic community the voice of
young leaders who are shaking our
conscience
and calling for action I heard you for
50 years the World Economic Forum has
always adapted to changing times while
preserving its original spirit the
agenda for the 50th anniversary of Davos
is clear it is building a sustainable
and cohesive world it is rising to the
great urgencies of today and tomorrow we
have come here today to discuss debate
and commit to solutions and to new
alliances to fight climate change to
strengthen inclusive growth to ensure
peace and prosperity for all dear
friends to conclude this ceremony the
European Youth Orchestra will play our
European anthem the old to joy it is the
perfect choice because when Europe
celebrates pays tribute respect or
mourns our European anthem sounds and
the words are sometime ancient ancient
but the meaning is timeless the ode to
joy' praises forgiveness and
reconciliation the ode to joy'
celebrates friendship the ode to joy
stands for unity and strength and this
is the spirit of Davos this is what
keeps bringing us together after so many
years there could be no better anthem to
celebrate the world's Economic Forum's
fiftieth anniversary
and this is for you Klaus and it is also
from the bottom of my heart for you
Hilda Hilda and Klaus have made Davos
what it is today we all pay tribute to
this life long achievement Thank You
Hilda Thank You Klaus
[Applause]